I think I said what more times in VHS
too than I ever have in that way in my
life
VHS 2 is yet another anthology film in
which she got a few short stories and
centered around these short stories is
another big story in which a person is
essentially going into this house they
find this giant VHS tape collection they
start putting them in and they watch
them and as they watch them we see what
they're seeing and they're basically
some short horror thriller films done by
various directors in Hollywood
now the first VHS film I actually really
liked I was very surprised how much that
movie actually frightened me and despite
the fact that I'm not a fan of that
shaky-cam found footage like genre I
really enjoyed VHS and so I was looking
forward to VHS 2 and hoping that it
wasn't just some quick cash grab because
this is a really quickly made sequel
obviously these films probably don't
take as long to make as some of the more
bigger budget Hollywood films but I was
still very interested to see where VHS 2
is going to go I will say this I don't
really think this movie is quite as
scary as the first one I do think though
that it is way more intense way more big
in regards to some of the things they're
able to accomplish as an overall movie
it feels slightly more complete than the
first one did but I do think that I just
enjoyed just how truly on edge the first
one made me because this film has more
of a comedy element to it because one of
the things that I didn't like but the
first one was that it did have all of
those horror cliche tropes at times but
it wasn't really making fun of that it
seemed like we're trying to still be
serious this film has some cliches and
tropes as well but some of the shorts
have a serious sense of humor going on
where you can actually laugh along with
some of the intensity that you do
witness the first short is about a guy
who gets this eye implant to help him
see and then he starts seeing really
strange things as he walks around
another short is about a guy who
actually turns into a zombie and you get
a first-person perspective of what a
zombie might be doing which is rather
clever and that one was pretty frickin
intense and had some great great effects
work in there now what many people
consider the best one was the short
called safe haven these people are
investigating a very mysterious
religious cult and stuff goes down
that's all I'll say there's also one
involving aliens and around all those
tapes is a woman in a man actually
watching them and each tape when it ends
you can
see them take it out and then they have
their little thoughts on it and
everything and creepy things are going
on in the background just like the first
one it really is essentially a copy of
the first one but it really isn't too
much else you can do with it what this
movie is really about and what the first
one is really about is really just
talented filmmakers coming together and
creating some interesting shorts and
finding a way to string them all
together in a very creepy way and I
enjoyed this film on that level it
really did bother me and creeped me out
and I was very impressed with a lot of
the ingenuity that was behind a lot of
this found footage because what I
usually don't like about found footage
is that shakey cam or that style to me
is a way to mask poor storytelling they
don't know what else to do so they'll
shake the camera and make you think
something's happening these films aren't
like that these films have genuinely
great effects work and I don't mean like
CGI I mean like great makeup effects
really really good camera tricks and I
was impressed with a lot of things they
were able to accomplish with these
movies know one of the things I said
about the first film in my original
review was that in regards to that movie
if you're the kind of person who wants
to go into a movie and have things
explained to you and have explanations
for things and have things all make
sense and wrap with a perfect little bow
then you were going to be ticked off
when you watch that movie if you were
ticked off when you watch that movie
you're going to be ticked off for this
movie maybe even more because there are
a lot of things in this movie that are
just really creepy that don't really
have an explanation one of my biggest
problems with this movie was the fact
that as the girl watches the VHS tapes
and she takes them out she's like huh
that was interesting then she just puts
the next one in dude if I found those
VHS tapes somewhere and was watching
them I would be flipping out I would be
questioning my sanity I'd be questioning
my existence and she's just like oh that
was interesting tape no that was
actually probably the freakiest thing
you more than likely ever witnessed
maybe show a little bit more emotion but
then there was like this whole storyline
that the tapes maybe do something to you
mentally so I guess that could maybe
cover for that possibly I guess I also
didn't like how it's honestly just a
complete copy off the original they
really didn't do anything to change the
sequencing of this movie I didn't really
expect them to though because this is
such a small thing if they make a third
one they might want to change it up a
little bit not have somebody just
invading a house and find some tapes and
watch them they might want to change it
up a little bit but I will say that the
way the film ended was definitely
creepier than the way the first one did
overall DHS 2 does what it wants to do
and it does it well but I do think this
is the start of a possible
eight horror franchise for our time here
because the 80s had Friday 13 Halloween
Freddy the 90s had scream the 2000s had
saw maybe the 2010s are going to have
the VHS films I'm gonna give VHS to Abby
I think it's a fun horror film it's
available right now for download on
almost every platform
I personally downloaded it off of the
PlayStation 3 store thanks as always for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck my
eyes